لم أفكر أبدًا في أنني كنت ذلك
الغريب المظهر الذي لا أعرفه ،
فأنا سأبحث على الإنترنت والناس سيكونون
مثل الأشياء الغريبة جدًا لهذه الفتاة ،
وكنت مثل ما أشعر به كأنني عادية
ولا أعرف وأعرف أنني '  م نوعًا ما
سأحصل على بعض التدعيم لهذا
النوع من الجرذ الفضائي عفريت عفريت نوع من الأجواء
وأذهب معها لا أعرف عائلتي
تتصل بي بمراكز التسوق وهذا هو السبب في أن
اسم العرض الخاص بي هو أنني لم أعتقد أبدًا
أنني أحب  انظر ، لقد كنت
طفلة غريبة جدًا ، كنت نحيفًا حقًا ، لقد كان
لدي أيضًا مثل unibrow في تلك
المرحلة ، ولا أحب أبدًا أن أفكر أبدًا في
أن الفتاة التي قضت معظم
طفولتها مع unibrow ستكون رائجة في إيطاليا لقد تم اكتشافها
في سوق للسلع الرخيصة والمستعملة  في
نيويورك من قبل وكيل في المجتمع
بعد أسبوع ، وبدأ كل شيء
يحدث في البداية ، أعتقد أن عرضي الأول
كان مرتبكًا حقًا وليس
ما كنت أتوقعه تمامًا ، لكن الآن يبدو
وكأنه مدرسة مثل
المصور مثل  المعلم أو
مدير اختيار الممثلين يقودنا إلى نوع ما
مثل معلمنا ، إذا كان أي شيء
سيصبح مبدعًا ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون
وجهًا بشعًا عند صنعه لأنه نوع
من الرجل لا أعرفه ، لقد اعتقدت دائمًا أنه إذا كان
لديك أشخاص يلتقطون صورًا لك ،
فلا تبتسم فقط مثل القيام بشيء غريب
مثل لماذا لا  الحصول على الاهتمام أو
أي شيء من حولك يحتاج الناس
لاحتضان تفردهم
والثقة والرائعة